what's up guys so recently in the past
few years
smart speakers have become very popular
and many different Quebec companies like
Amazon Google and even Apple I've
created their version of the best smart
speaker with their own software and
features to fit as a result they have
poured millions of dollars into research
and advertising these products and in
the end they really have made them a
household item the entry-level models
are quite affordable and retail for
around $50 but to do get a lot more
expensive and recently Amazon was like
why don't we plop a screen on it and
make it more feature-rich this led to
the creation and release of the Amazon
echo show which retails for I want two
hundred and twenty nine dollars for a
Bluetooth speaker that can take in some
commands and has a queen personally I
don't really understand the use of this
and I would never use it however this
product is still very popular and so I
decided to delve into this topic a
little bit more as I was looking through
this ream of tech I noticed that Google
was developing their own version of the
Amazon echo show with a codename of
Manhattan the Google Manhattan is it
rumored to have a seven inch screen with
support for video calls Google Photos
blue assistant and YouTube
some reports even suggest that this is
why Google suddenly stopped the support
of YouTube with several of Amazon's
products they said that this was because
Amazon violated the Terms of Service and
undermined the user experience however
this may be the real reasons the most
recent set of statistics show that
Amazon controls about 70 percent of the
smart speaker market while Google only
controls 25 percent so obviously who is
trying to steal some of the market share
the price and details of this device are
yet to be released
but it will be probably at 200 this
product was expected to be revealed by
Google on their October 4th event but in
the event that I only revealed a few
phones and a few other speakers so this
product is still mostly in the dark well
guys that's all I have for you guys
about this product let me know what
you're thinking about this in the
comments below about
whether it be crazy expensive like the
Apple home pot at 350 dollars or will it
be more budget oriented product or do
you think this will never be released
what do you guys think about Virtual
Assistants as a whole or what do you
think about adding a screen to them I'm
really interested in y'all's thoughts
so make sure to comment them that's all
I have for you guys today if you guys
like this video make sure to drop a like
on this video if you guys love this
video and would like to see more videos
just like this then make sure to
subscribe and hit that Bell notification
but that's all I have for you guys today
and until next video bye